so
today we're going to continue in our
discussion
of uh dynamic programming i actually
found
this set of problem session problems to
be easier than the previous one
i think the fun there's a funny thing
which is uh
we learned in class about sort of
pseudo-polynomial time
style dynamic programs somehow that
language is a little bit
liberating in the sense that you're sort
of using parameters that you really
shouldn't
uh when it comes to the runtime of your
algorithm well i suppose you should in
the sense that it's allowed if you call
your
algorithm pseudo polynomial time but
somehow it makes it a little easier to
formulate your dynamic programming
algorithm because sort all the numbers
are staring you
right in the face like you don't have to
be so careful about what's uh
fair game and what's not uh when you
when you post your algorithm
so long as it's sufficient in the values
that you care about
uh and so today's problem session has
five problems squeezed in instead of the
usual four
we'll see how far we get seeing that i
usually talk too much anyway uh
but i'll try to stay on schedule here
and we'll see how well we do
um any questions from our students about
dynamic programming before we get
started here
we can cut one oh i i will gladly cut
one if i run out of time
yeah okay so without further ado
uh let's get started with the coin
crafting which is problem
9-1 here so
i suppose it should be keel nafri if i
were to
work through my spoonerism properly here
um in any event we have a thief who's in
desperate need of money
as with many thieves or else of course
they wouldn't resort to the world of
crime
uh and uh kiel nafri here
um has uh n identical
coins
i've been very self-conscious about the
way that i write the letter i ever since
eric pointed it out and it's only gotten
worse now it's inconsistent
and and hard to read uh but in any event
uh so we have uh n uh identical coins
and of course you know these coins have
very distinctive markings and so we
can't possibly
run away with them as is because if you
take them to your standard jeweler
they'll immediately
recognize that these markings are bad
and stolen and that's not so good so
instead
we can melt uh these coins into other
objects
so uh you know our sneaky thief here
has identified a potential buyer and uh
the buyer has a few criteria here right
so we have a buyer
um and the buyer has
the buyer has a very strange value
system saying that apparently it's easy
to
take coins and make them into other
things uh but but in an event
the the buyer what they care about is
not the fact that the coins are made of
gold
but rather that they like particular
objects
better than others made out of said gold
um
so in particular they have a different
rate for each object like a different
price they're willing to pay
and so they have a list of um
and objects that they're interested in
uh and
each one uh is associated with two
things
and objects uh they have a price
so the amount of the buyer is willing to
pay for that object which again is not
just the weight in gold for some reason
you know there's a value-added tax uh in
in in
this universe uh and uh it takes a
different number of coins
to manufacture
right like so maybe you know i can make
like a
golden chocolate fountain and that takes
like 10 coins
but i don't want two of those so if i
make that then the next thing i have to
do is like a figurine of eric and jason
to put alongside it
um and having more than one of those
would also be like creepy and weird
right so so i can only make one of each
object uh and of course
uh my goal here is i have n coins by the
way the fact that there's n coins and n
objects for the buyer doesn't really
matter i mean it will for the run time
but like you could imagine this being n
and
um so i wouldn't be too hung up on that
um
and what you're trying to do is is of
course maximize your revenue
uh subject to the constraints that uh
you have n coins uh and you can't make
two objects that are the same
hopefully i've captured the essence of
our problem okay
okay fabulous so uh as with uh all of
our
our dynamic programming problems in
6.006
we have a paradigm for how to approach
them
um which has a cute acronym which is
sort bot
and i think sort bot is a totally
relevant and straightforward
approach to this problem here yeah so uh
in particular
let's give ourselves a bit of of
notation right so we're gonna number our
objects between
one and n uh just for convenience so
we'll say that uh
p i is the price
of uh object i
okay and uh we'll say that
k i is the what the problem calls the
melting
number in other words if i want to make
object i this is the amount of coins
that i'd have to
melt to to make that object okay so just
a tiny bit of notation
and in general so okay what do we do
when we formulate our dynamic
programming problems
we want to identify interesting
subproblems we could solve that are
smaller
and when we compose them all together we
get the final solution to our problem
in this particular problem uh involving
manufacturing objects out of coins i
think
is like a really classic one when it
comes to dynamic programming like this
is the sort of thing where
you know someday when you're trying to
to pay for your tuition by doing these
like hacker contests online you know
like this is the sort of thing that
comes up all the time in that universe
right
um so in particular uh
the two sort of variables here uh you
know when i make a new object is what
object did i make
and how many coins did i spend when i
did that so the
sort of the two natural parameters to
use uh when i solve my dynamic uh
programming problem
yeah and and of course it's going to be
sort of recursive in the sense that
um i can either choose to make object
i or not and it doesn't matter what
order i make my objects in
or similarly what order i spend my coins
in which is usually a nice property to
have in
uh dynamic programming universe so in
particular
oh this thing is my nemesis um
this is front
i think this classroom is particularly
tough for short people because it's like
i'm moving it up and down all the time
okay uh so given our observation here uh
if we're doing
sort but uh right so
what's our s again let me ask myself
that sub problems thank you
professor domain uh then essentially
what we want to do
based on what i sort of argued verbally
is maybe define
our variable x ij the thing we're going
to compute to be
the revenue
uh from using i
coins uh
and uh objects uh one to j
okay so in other words you know i have i
coins left in the bank and i'm only
allowed to use the first j
objects and we can already see that
there's kind of a sensible way to
approach this
dynamic programming problem in the sense
that you know there's an obvious
recursion here i choose to make an
object i have fewer coins
and i can sort of imagine there being a
topological order
in the sense that i could first decide
about object one and then object two and
object three and so on
or vice versa depending on whether
you're a prefix or suffix kind of guy
um which i still get backward but the
the good news is that uh it doesn't
really matter what matters is
formulating the equation
okay any questions about our definition
of the thing that we're gonna chase
after here
fabulous
okay right so
uh let's do uh let's continue sort bot
so our next uh
uh piece of our puzzle here is the r i
believe r
stands for recursion this is a new
acronym for me too oop nope we're late
but it might as well be recursion for
most of these problems uh
right so the basic relationship here is
that of course i can either use object j
or i can not use object j
uh and in both of those cases right if j
is the very last guy that i'm going to
consider
that'll be a totally reasonable
recursive rule right so in particular
um i have that uh x i j
um essentially can take one of two
values so
parenthesis in case you're wondering um
and and of course you're trying to
maximize your revenue
uh so so let's do that okay so um
so we have sort of two object
potentially potential options but we
have to be
a bit careful is there a case where i
can't make object j
yes class there is uh which is uh the
case where i don't have enough coins
left in the bank right so
i want to make that really expensive
fountain but i only have one coin then
i'm sort of out of luck
yep so uh let's do these two cases so
first
um you know if
oops i got my cases backward that's okay
um right so let's say that i choose not
to uh make uh
object j okay so what does that mean so
did i spend any coins
no and moreover what is my uh maximum
profit well it's gonna be the same as
the maximum profit
using objects one through j minus one
because i didn't use object j
yeah so in particular that would be x
um let's see i got it backward in my
notes so we're gonna do it live
uh like that okay
and otherwise let's say that i did
choose to make object j
well what happened so i did get some
revenue now
right so i got man what on earth did i
write on these uh
um so i get the uh price of object j
here
as my revenue but i spend uh some coins
in the process so i have i
minus uh k sub i which is the number of
coins
what was that oh thank you sorry k sub j
and that's why we should be consistent
with our indices when we write these
things down
um right so i spent case of j coins
uh making this thing uh object j
uh and uh moreover i can still choose to
make any of the previous objects so it's
still just j minus one
but i have to be careful because i can't
always do this
in particular this had better be a
positive number if i and or at least a
non-negative number because if i end up
with a negative number of coins
well that that's not a physical universe
that i choose to be in
uh so in particular uh what we need in
some sense is i
minus k minus j kj to be greater or
equal to zero
or equivalently i is greater than or
equal to k so j
thank you guys could i'll do that one at
home okay and this is our recursion uh
hopefully i've gotten it right because
it disagrees with the crazy thing i
wrote in my notes at 1 am yesterday
but i think it's pretty straightforward
essentially either i can choose to use
the last object or i choose not to
and either one of those uh of course
decrements uh j
because that's the index of the object
i'm considering and i either account for
the price
but have to pay in gold or i don't
account for the price so implicitly
there's a zero and i don't have to pay
and gold
okay good all right so let's continue
with uh
sort bot we might later in the problem
session
relax going through every one of these
steps because a lot of the arguments are
kind of similar but for now
we'll do one or two carefully so t uh
i believe stands for topological order
uh and here it's
staring us in the face because notice
that um
x i j only
depends on um
x i x question mark comma j minus one
right so of course on your problem set
you should write things more carefully
uh but the basic point here is that
there's a clear topological order
just by looking at that second index
because you kind of if you think of all
of your x's as variables in a graph
which
we've actually drawn in lecture so like
maybe these are all the eyes
and then you know the j you know so like
i goes down
and j goes to the right then essentially
this argument is saying that all the
arrows
kind of point left in this graph
um i suppose the way i've drawn my
arrows this isn't quite accurate but it
actually doesn't matter the only thing
that matters is that it goes from right
to left
um but i'm going to erase this so i
don't remember it
okay so in general just when you when
you want to make your topological order
argument i think a totally sensible one
is like looking at the indices of your
recursion and then just trying to find
some number that decreases
incidentally if you take a differential
equation course uh that's roughly how
you prove that a lot of those things
converge too um
so there's a sort of a generic math
trick that we use a lot
you call that in in ode where you have
some number that
decreases i would call it potential
function potential function that's a
perfectly sensible one there's the
it's not lip [ __ ] it's some other
mathematician anyway
uh okay so let's continue uh sort bots
so next we need b
which is our base case uh so in this
case uh it's pretty straightforward if i
if i don't have any coins i can't make
any money
i have a t-shirt that says that at home
uh and
moreover if i can't sell anything i
can't make any money
so those are pretty straightforward
cases so we have that zero
equals x of 0
comma j remember the first index is the
number of coins you have so this is
saying
i don't i can't make anything i don't
have any coins and similarly
equals x i comma 0
for all i j right so
this is the coins and the uh objects
okay so let's see i keep writing these
problem sessions too big and then
spending half of it erasing so let's
let's try and fit this on one board here
so we're going to do sort bot then the
second no the first o because there's no
o and sort
um is the uh what the original problem
that you want to solve
so of course you start out with n
objects and
n coins so
the original problem we want to solve uh
is equivalent to computing x
n comma n and then finally we got to do
our run time
t stands for runtime or time i suppose
um so first of all how many subproblems
are there well there's
x i j both i can go from zero to
n this is a great way to be off by one
um so there's n
plus one squared sub
problems uh and how much work does each
sub problem do
well it does boring work it's just a
formula
right so there's order one work
per sub problem so the overall algorithm
takes n squared time so
i promised to do something last in our
last prom session then i didn't actually
do it
uh so i did think i would spend just a
minute uh here
sort of translating what this sort bot
thing would mean
in terms of of code because i think that
it's a little bit implicit here
in particular i think this step here i
mean it
you will see that it really clearly is
going to give you an algorithm but i
think it's kind of easy to like
again just to forget what what your code
actually looks like and actually the
coding problems on these
prompt sessions are almost too
interesting and and can obscure it a
little bit
so i thought we'd do a boring problem
and show you uh that it's really not so
hard to
to do this and in fact uh we covered two
different strategies in class
for how to take sort bot and convert it
into a piece of code
although they might have kind of zipped
past you in this you know 2x
speed uh thing that you can do now um
so right so here are two options um one
of them is called memoization
uh and the other i don't know bottom up
i guess is a reasonable phrase uh to
describe
and so i thought we'd do them both
because they're both easy for this
particular problem
um okay
right so um let's do that so let's
uh so is this necessary on your homework
strictly speaking no like if
you've gone through sort by then
essentially everything that happens
after that is sort of boilerplate in
terms of converting these steps into
a piece of code or an algorithm but i do
think just for understanding
why sort by makes sense it's worth
thinking about for a minute
so option a here is memoization
ironically i've taught and t8 algorithms
a few times and i never actually knew
what memoization
uh meant so i learned something from
eric's lecture the other day
um which remember memoization the key
thing and then what apparently is kind
of a made up word is memo
like you know if you're back in the day
and you had a lot of steno pad
and you were writing down stuff because
that's where you solve problems with
your
slide rule um then essentially the idea
is that
if i compute x i j for some i j pair i
shouldn't compute it again i should just
write it down on my memo pad
um stenoization sounds better to me but
i suppose i'd have to go back to the 19
what 40s and fix it
um okay so let's actually
write down i'm going to write down
pseudocode that'll probably look more
like matlab because i'm that kind of guy
so let's say that i wanted to make a
function
which i guess is revenue
of i j uh like that
um and and and this is the thing i
wanted to compute
uh that's actually gonna be a problem
because we're not gonna be able to see
okay right so in addition to this
i'm going to kind of pass in an array x
um which is going to be like the my memo
pad this is going to be
terrible coding practice but easy board
coding uh practice so like if i'm in c
plus maybe i pass it by reference so
that like when i edit
it's a treble clef but whatever uh
you know when i edit x it actually
persists when i when i recurse
this is terrible coding practice and you
shouldn't do it okay
but it's just going to be because i
don't want to write too many lines on
the board here
um and maybe we initialize like we have
some helper function
uh to let's see we want our revenue to
be big well
actually no we'll just initialize it to
like not a number so that like we know
that we haven't computed it yet how
about that
okay so uh
what should we do well if we're going to
memoize the first thing we should do
anytime that i call my revenue function
on on an ij pair is check i've already
computed it yeah
um so in my kind of goofy bad board
coding style here
what could i do i'd say well if i've
already computed it then this thing
won't equal
nan anymore it won't be not a number so
i can say okay
if x i j
does not equal not a number so in other
words it is a number
um return
and this like i think that this little
line of code here it gets like a little
lost but this is like
we should put like sparkles around it
right this is the magic of dynamic
programming
because i just killed recursive calls
right like
i even if i and j are like 17 and 23
if i already computed it i'm done right
i don't have to call my recursion again
okay and otherwise what am i gonna do
um well otherwise i'll
you know maybe call do i want to write
it all down
i don't want to write it all down um
so otherwise i'm going to evaluate
r where r is this formula over here
notice that
this will require um recursive calls
right and i'm going to store it in x
i j and then return x ij
okay so basically the only difference
between like what we've seen in the
first two thirds of 6006 and now
is this beautiful line of code saying if
i already computed this thing return it
and this is the memoized version of our
algorithm
um i think this is sort of the easiest
one to maybe
think about but actually from a runtime
analysis it's a little bit annoying
um it's not in the sense that we
convinced ourselves that sort bot is
okay
but of course like if you're thinking
about your recursion tree like what's
happening is that you're sort
of maybe convincing yourself that like
this piece can be
lopped off in your function calls um so
you sort of have to do your counting uh
carefully
uh there's a different way to uh
implement the same thing so this would
be option b
this is maybe more efficient maybe less
efficient depending on your problem
but these are all within constant
factors of each other for the most part
not always but for the most part this
would be bottom up
and this is the idea of rather than just
taking our recursive algorithm that we
already know
and then just like checking a table to
say like okay i already do this in this
in that case return it
uh in the bottom up version i'm gonna
build up my array x i j um
so there's no recursion at all um
so right so what would that look like so
in the bottom up case
notice that in some sense the
memorization is a top down strategy
right i would call it on
n comma n here we're going to start from
0 and work our way toward
n right so we'll start with x 0
j equals
x i zero equals 0 for all i
j obviously i can do this with a for
loop
uh and now well remember if we think
about our topological order
x i j only depends on previous js
right so it makes sense to have an outer
loop which is over j
and now inside inside of this outer loop
i can
compute anything that i want in that j
column of x and i'm in good shape
because i'm building it up
uh one column at a time right so in
particular now we can do
you know our loop over i and then just
have you know
x j um and now
you know evaluate our r step in our sort
bot uh paradigm and and notice that
that's perfectly fine because by the
time i get
to computing x i j i've already filled
in x i j for
you know minus one which is all i needed
to evaluate that formula
so what are the advantages and the
disadvantages here so notice that here
our our runtime is staring you in the
face right we have
n squared sub problems order one work
and you're done
on the other hand there's some
possibility like if you were
an old school ai person that you might
be able to do some pruning
on on the the your left hand side
uh that i can't do over here right so
here i'm literally evaluating every
entry of x i j
it could be the case it's not the case
for this particular problem but
maybe x i j only depends on x i j minus
phi
right this strategy is going to still
build up that whole table this one maybe
can skip over some entries so in
practice it could help on the other hand
here i've got a bunch of recursive calls
i was put on the stack of my computer
that here i don't have
so i think actually because of the
overhead of recursion typically
the strategy on the right is is
preferred also for clarity but that's a
blanket statement that i shouldn't make
okay so anyway i think i've i've done
this uh this problem to death
uh are there any uh questions here i
just thought i'd fill in for something i
promised last time and and didn't
actually do
okay fabulous so we'll go on
to problem nine two um so this is
continuing from last time in the
saga of tim the beaver here so i forget
what
tim the beaver was doing in our last
problem session but today
tim the beaver is going to the career
fair
and as we all know the only real purpose
of going to a career fair
is to pick up free stuff um
you know we joke actually you guys
should all go to the career fair i i got
my first job out of college by going to
a career fair um and her ringing
somebody at pixar booth until they let
me in
uh but in any event um
so tim the beaver uh is not interested
in getting a job but rather
just wants uh swag just wants free stuff
out of booths at the career fair
okay uh so in in this particular problem
there's and booths
is it booths certainly not boots um
i don't know they're n booths uh each of
which has uh swag
and in particular each swag has
a value associated to it which is ci
which is the coolness
of object i uh it additionally has
wi this is the weight
of object i and
just to make this problem verbally
difficult to communicate there's a
w-a-i-t
associated with each object which is the
time
it takes to wait in line and pick up
object i
okay and and tim the beaver like if
there's some ridiculously cool object
with like a low wait time he might just
keep getting in line and and getting
more of that object so unlike
um kiel nafri on our first problem
uh tim the beaver is perfectly happy to
have more than one of the same thing
okay um
in addition to this uh just to make this
problem
in my opinion slightly more annoying and
point losing
um tim the beaver also takes one minute
to get in line at any booth
um so we're just gonna have to remember
that when we account for our time ti
okay so uh
let's continue adding some more
constants to our problem
so each uh booth has an object which has
coolness ci weight wi
time ti tim is carrying a
bag the bag
has uh can can hold
a particular weight b um so this is the
max
weight that tim
uh can hold in his bag at any given time
uh and finally you know
tim is a greedy beaver but he also uh
can go home uh you know or go back to
his damn
i suppose uh and empty his bag
right and so h is the amount of time
uh to go home
uh and back uh
and and empty his bag in the meantime
and again
just to be annoying don't forget he
encouraged plus one to get in the next
line
this is what made my answer wrong and
i'm bitter so i'm going to keep
complaining about it
okay so of course uh what he wants
is the max you know it's sort of a
what would economists uh call this i i
don't know but but for for tim the
beaver
he wants the max total
coolness or mtc uh which is of course a
number that we're all trying to optimize
um in k minutes
like you might remember those old tv
shows where you get like some like one
minute in a grocery store to
empty the shelves into your cart uh kind
of thing um
so he wants to do this and and
uh the computation time that he's
reserved for this is
order and n-b-k i know that was a big
setup i tried to document all the
different
constants um that are in this problem
that i don't think i missed any here
okay fabulous so incidentally you know
continuing on
[Music]
k k is the total amount of time uh that
tim the beaver has allotted uh to
do his job fair uh uh scavenging
fabulous uh right any other
cool okay um
notice that this is going to be an
example of of a problem that was sort of
not kosher in last week's problem
session in the sense that k is included
in our runtime
right but like what is k it's just a
number it k
it doesn't scale on the size of your
problem in a linear way
um so it's not going to matter for how
we solve our problem but it is just a
feature that's worth uh pointing out
okay so how do we solve uh dynamic
programming problems we use uh swordpod
um or a senior bst uh
if you are watching previous iterations
of this course
okay so uh right so let's let's do that
see i'm trying to conserve board spaces
this is not going to end up
succeeding so again like what are all
the different
sub problems here well somehow what are
what are the different things that
are limiting tim the beaver you know
what are what are his
uh constraints well he only has so much
time
and somehow this is going to sound more
philosophical than any in
intent but but you know time always
moves forward for tim the beaver
there's a pretty good candidate uh in
terms of dynamic programming because
there's not going to be some cyclical
dependency remember that
in dynamic programming we're all about
trying to identify topological orderings
in our sub problems
and when you see something like time not
only does it also begin with t
uh but it's it's useful in the sense
that time moves forward
uh there's never a case where tim the
beaver
you know purchases like a weird warp
speed airplane and somehow goes back in
time
um that doesn't happen in this
particular homework problem and and for
tim the beaver's sake i hope
and no homework problems um so
instead of the so so there's a
long-winded way of saying that time
is a pretty reasonable uh constraint to
put in our problem
not constraint as much as uh index i
guess
moreover there's another thing which is
uh limiting
tim the beaver which is the capacity of
his bag remember he can only hold weight
uh b but this one
should give you the heebie-jeebies a
little bit because this problem
as a twist has allowed
the bag to empty itself out right so
it's not true
that somehow you can come up with some
sub-problems
where um tim the beaver is just
monotonically decreasing the weight of
his bag
however if he does choose to decrease
the weight of his bag
he has to spend time doing it so time
continues to move forward for tim the
beaver
and that's what's going to give us our
topological order yeah
this is a little too philosophical i
guess but in some sense
this is a long-winded way of saying for
our sort bot paradigm here
um a totally reasonable thing to do
would be to have
x i j
i don't think in this class we do this
definition notation so just x i j
equals the max coolness
where he has i minutes
uh and he has j weight
let me glance at my answer to see if
it's left in his bag or
weight that he's carrying left in his
back
either one would make a reasonable uh
problem i'm just bad at
looking at my notes and seeing them
disagree with the board so i'm going to
try and
stay consistent okay so x i j is
the mtc but in i minutes with j weight
left rather than
in k minutes with b weight
which is going to be our base uh problem
okay oh no i did it out of order
like disregard that we'll get to the b
in a minute okay
okay so now uh so so that's our our uh
subproblems
so now uh let's do the r in swordpop
i hate this classroom so much
i'm sorry right so so let's say the the
the tim the beaver uh
has has i minutes left in the clock uh
and he has j weight in his bag he's got
a number of actions that he can take
yeah uh and and let's think about what
all those actions are by the way
there's one thing that plausibly
tim the beaver could do but he doesn't
really need to
is like do nothing now but then in 10
seconds do something
like it's just you could account for
that in this problem but like there's
there's sort of not a reason right like
he might as well stack up all of his
actions and then
leave all of his left over time at the
end um
you convince yourself that that's sort
of okay you know tim prefers a
compressed uh schedule
um right so he's got a lot of energy
this beaver that's what they say their
nature is uh
construction workers or something okay
right so let's think about all of our
options so for one
tim the beaver could not do a damn thing
he could just sit around for the rest of
time
and and that would be perfectly fine so
a different way of putting that
um is that he could give up how much
coolness
would tim get from giving up zero
that's right kids giving up makes you
zero
cool um so okay uh right so
um tim the beaver is trying to maximize
uh he has a lot of different options
one of them is zero meaning
he gave up right
notice he could recurse like x i guess
what would be
you know he could give up for one minute
right and have that be
x i minus one j or something um
i forget if i'm going to do i plus 1 or
i minus i minus 1 j
but there's no reason like he can just
give up and stop like that would just be
extra recursive cost
for no good reason okay the next thing
that he could do
is he could get in line for a booth
right
um so first let's work out what happens
uh then so
for one um he gets coolness let's say
that he gets into booth k
so he gets coolness ck when he does that
and now he can recurse so first we have
to account for the time so it takes i
so it takes t k that's a t
time or does it no because it takes an
extra minute for him to get in the next
line
or to get in this line i guess this is
better um
and moreover uh
he needs to account for j minus w
k like that can he always do this no
he needs to have this much time
remaining and he needs this much time
in his bag or this much weight
remaining in his bag you guys can work
out the inequality but since i only have
a foot here
i'll just say if applicable
this is a great way to lose points on
your homework uh but for board writing
it's okay so
when i say applicable i mean these two
numbers have better be greater than or
equal to zero
okay uh and you can do this for all k
right so in other words he can choose to
get into booth k
and tim has the third option which is he
can go home
okay so what happens if he goes home
does he is he cool when he
does tim the beaver get cooler when he
goes home no
i'm afraid to to say so um
in particular but he does spend time
yeah so how much time does he spend
age
what was that you should have lost
coolness by going home
no home is cool guys especially this
semester
stay home stay indoors um so he he uh
right so he he loses uh home time h and
one to get in the next line okay um
but you know he's got a devil's bargain
of sorts uh he he
he loses time but he gains bag
bagginess weight is the word that i'm
looking for
um b like that okay um again
in this case remember that he still
needs if i is greater than
h right otherwise uh he's in trouble
by the way i wrote this in kind of an
annoying way this is a different way of
saying that is i minus h
minus one is greater than or equal to
zero which is really what's applicable
in our recursive call but this is a
strict
greater than sign that was another
little thing that caught me up when i
was reading the answer here
okay and those are all the options for
tim the beaver yeah um
notice that every one of our options
either gives up completely
or decreases time so
we have our topological order which is
again that the arrow of time always
continues to move forward
i'm going to prove that rigorously by
putting a check mark next to the letter
t
again on your homework you should write
out your answers uh what is our
base case for tim well
how much coolness do you get if you have
no time
zero coolness that's how much um so
we have this expression x zero j equals
zero for all
j incidentally um although it's
perfectly fine to have this be your base
case
you actually in some sense didn't need
it because tim the beaver always had the
option of giving up
um so you could i guess in this problem
have no base case if you really wanted
um would be okay but kind of weird
um okay and what's our original problem
well he starts out with time k and uh
weight
uh capacity b in his bag so it's x
k b and then finally
uh we need to do our runtime analysis
so how many subproblems are there well
again a sub problem is basically just
the number of
indexes for for most of our dynamic
programming problems
right so there's um
[Music]
so the first index is time the second
one
is bag size
this is always between 0 and b this is
always between 0 and k
so there's order k b
sub problems
how much time does each sub problem take
well notice that i have to loop
over all of my different options k here
so i
incur
oh i'm noticing k
is abused in our answer to this problem
we should use k only once
okay so here's here's here's where uh i
made a mistake and i believe it's in the
written solution but i'm not going to
check now
um there's k which is the total time
that tim the beaver has and there's the
k that i use as an index here
and those are are not the same i guess i
can make this k
bar really fast there you go problem
solved
and i just noticed that because i was
doing my runtime and it's not order k
um it's the loop over all the k bars
[Laughter]
how many k bars are there well these are
all the different booths and there's our
n of those so this is order n
time per sub problem
which gives me a total run time of order
k
b and um which i believe
uh oh our desired runtime was order nbk
but i think we can convince ourselves
that indeed those are the same thing
okay so my apologies for a slight uh uh
overloaded uh
character here but honestly it's kind of
one of those things if you read the
answer you probably wouldn't even notice
but now that i'm saying it out loud i
am okay and that uh solves uh tim the
beaver's uh maximization problem
he's a very cool beaver any uh any
questions about this one
notice that both of these problems are
are very similar in nature i basically
just wrote some problems indexed by
every possible thing
uh and then enumerated every possible
solution uh i think this is totally
sensible like i again i remember i had a
math professor in college that always
would use this phrase like it's
important not to think here
um and i think this is absolutely true
for these dynamic programming problems
somehow they look a lot more complicated
than they are
fabulous so problem three protein
parsing ah yeah so this one
this one also got me tripped up for a
minute because the runtime they want is
not
the runtime of the obvious solution but
it kind of sort of is after a little bit
of uh
uh fixing okay so
uh professor uh larry ander uh has a
laboratory
and that laboratory processes dna
um okay so let me go to my notes here
because i think they're easier to read
right so a strand of dna as we all know
because we're mit students
uh is is equal to basically a strand of
characters that are like a c
t and g if you asked me to name what
those
stood for i i could make a stab at like
one or two of them but
i'm a failure of a like i did not have
the gir
because i went to stanford and this is
why i'm apparently a
poorly educated person according to a
person in a faculty meeting
um but in any event um
right so we have a strand of dna is
basically a long string of characters
that are one of four options i'm told
that there's sometimes like a fifth and
a sixth option but not too often
this problem there's not um
and uh moreover um so a strand can be
cut up
so i have this big long strand and i'm
looking for certain like
markers in particular i have a list
p of uh markers
which are really a sequence
of less than or equal to k
nucleotides
by the way this really is uh something
that the people do like like string
searching really is
applicable to processing these dna
strands obviously
i think in in practice these techniques
have to be a lot more resilient to
error um but really a lot of these
algorithms we're covering are not all
that far off
from from how people process these giant
data sets which is pretty cool
i think um okay so
what are we going to do well we have a
string
and then we're going to make a division
um
so we'll call our string s and our
division d
which kind of looks like d one
to d m which are uh sub strings
uh that concatenate to make uh the full
the full guy
so if s is our our
input string then a division d is just
like chopping up s into little
substrings uh each of which we can give
a name
little d here so big d is the full
uh division little d is is all the
little pieces
you know there's that that old song
about going through the big d and domi
in dallas
i think it's for divorce i don't know um
right so uh
okay so the value
of a division
is the number of strands
so strands are these little d's here
that are in our list p
okay and so right so given
s and p what we want is the max value
and the run time that we're budgeted is
kind of a weird run time and this should
make us a little suspicious
um so the the max value is
big o of i think
i wrote it slightly differently in the
problem but whatever i distributed a k
like that so it's k mod p plus k squared
mod s right so so
we have two terms here which somehow
smells funny in dynamic programming
okay so what are we to do well
what i did is i ignored our desired run
time
came up with a dynamic program and
noticed that it was a little wrong
and then fixed it by wrong i mean it was
correct it just wasn't fast enough
okay so let's do version one here
one point oh that makes it more accurate
um they're more precise right i always
confuse those two
uh so so here's a sort of thing that
it's going to be a little bit funny
because it's going to look like we're
going to have an easy computational
problem
but then it's going to turn out that
it's actually too slow so in particular
uh in our s in swordbot what we could do
is say
x i is going to be the max
value of a suffix
if you're wondering i don't know the
difference between prefix and suffix but
i wrote the word suffix in my notes and
checked it at home
um s i comma colon
see it's suffix because it starts at i
and it goes to the end
huh
in matlab it would be a comma and that's
a colon
and that's an i okay
thanks um i'm inventing my own
programming language on the board as we
go today
all right so um and notice this is kind
of reasonable set of sub problems
right because kind of obviously if i if
i lop off
you know some some piece of my string
then the max value i can get is just the
the value of whatever remains yeah so
spiritually this somehow feels like the
right
uh uh dynamic programming and indeed
we'll see that it is but it just
requires a little bit of
lipstick at the end to run on the right
time okay
so let's do a recursive call
and this is actually straightforward
um at least the sort of recursive call
that you want to make uh is
straightforward and then we'll see that
there's an equivalent formula
which is the one you'll see in the
solution which looks more complicated
but it is the same thing so
i'm going to write it as pseudo code for
a recursive call rather than as one
giant formula because i think it's
easier to follow
not pseudocode i know that's that's
frowned upon in this class a
a description of a set of steps for
obtaining our recursive call rather than
a formula so in particular uh we're
going to initialize
x i to be zero
uh we want to do a maximization problem
so initializing our variable to zero is
a sensible thing to do
and remember what can we do here so
we're looking at a suffix
i could go down my list p of all the
different markers
see if any of them matches the first
couple characters of my string
if it does i get some value and then i
hop onto the next thing
that makes sense um
oops i'm realizing i have a slight
mistake here um
rather than initializing to zero
i actually have one additional option
that i forgot to account for because i
could just not use
this character i could i could i could
put it in its own little snippet and and
get no value
from it right so maybe initially i make
a recursive call like that
it would be okay to initialize it to
zero and then do this but whatever
notice we're already seeing the t and
our sort bot start to kind of stick out
at us we're going to only depend on
bigger indices i
okay but in addition to this this isn't
enough right this would
obviously just recurse the end of our
list and do nothing
we get value if we can find a substring
that's in our
our list so what we could do is
for each marker
in p remember p is the list of things
that we're looking for
okay um what could i do uh
if the marker
matches um
s starting at i
i'm gonna just not even attempt to do
python uh starting at i
and ending at the length of the marker
well what could i do i could get one
dollar by by mark you know by matching
that object
and then i have to hop forward the
length of the string uh in my recursive
call right so
um
well i could do that or i could not do
that and i want to maximize right so
i can keep my old value or um i could
get one point by using this as my match
plus x i plus um
the length of the marker okay
and this is actually in my mind the
simplest possible dynamic program you
could come up with this is actually a
totally
fine dynamic program we'll just see that
the runtime isn't good enough
okay so does everybody agree this is a
way i could solve this
this problem and it would give me a
correct answer
um i'll do the
t-bot yeah that's what we're going to do
but we're going to maybe skip some parts
of sort bot
um so in particular what's the
topological order notice that i always
look to the right
when i make a recursive call what's my
base
case well in this case it's just uh
x of zero i guess because i'm looking
forward oh
i'm sorry my base case is x of the whole
length of the string which is going to
return zero
right because if i have no string i
can't get any value out of it
the original is x of 0 meaning that i
want the whole string
and let's actually do the runtime
analysis as
jason suggests because that's of course
the relevant
computation here so this is
t two because it's the second t
in sort five okay so
how many sub problems are there well
there's i mean it almost looks like we
should have a fast algorithm because our
sub problems are only indexed by i
right um so there's one sub problem um
for basically each character in the
string so there's
mod s sub problems total
but how much time does it take for each
sub problem well let's be careful
so there's a for loop over all the
markers in p
so i know that i incur
at least mod p work in my sub problem
is that all the work that i incur
it kind of looks like it because there's
only one for loop and there's an if but
how do i check if strings are equal well
i have to iterate
over the length of the string so i incur
a second cost which is checking if two
strings are equal
we know that our strings are at most
well i didn't actually write it down but
the problem tells us that
our strings are at most length k
so i incur another factor of k
in every one of my sub problems and that
implies that our whole
algorithm that i've outlined for y'all
above takes
mod s k squared
oh i'm sorry that's a lie if i actually
multiply these things together
what i get
i need more sleep s p k
and that is against the rules that's
frowny face
yeah uh because in particular i took two
big numbers in some sense and multiplied
them together
uh and and and that's no good so
what what is a person to do you know i
tried to solve my problem i came up with
by the way for from a partial credit
perspective i think you'd be doing
okay if you got to to this point okay
not great but okay
um but of course the problem is
is asking you uh to solve this in this
funny uh run time which is k
p plus k squared uh uh s
yup when i see a sum like this in a
you know remember that there are two
problems to solve there are two
strategies for solving problems in
algorithms class there's one which
is useful in your everyday lives which
is to devise algorithms
there's a second which is to
psychologically diagnose your
instructors
um and i think the second strategy is
actually pretty effective here i see two
terms
most of our dynamic programming things
involve filling in a table where you
would expect there to be a product
so in general i would kind of squint at
this and think like hmm
maybe i have to do some pre-computation
yep
in particular um we got to do a lot of
string matching
in our problem and maybe we can make
that more efficient yeah that's sort of
the
the main question here um right so so
this thing is too slow and we're trying
to fix it
the way i'm going to try and fix it is
to say like okay
well i have mod s sub problems if i look
at these two terms how much work can i
actually do in my sub problem something
that looks like k squared
maybe plus this amount of precomputation
see what i did there
okay so let's uh let's do that
so in particular here are the types of
queries that i'm going to have to make
there's a bunch of times in my code when
uh here's a
number that yikes falling apart
that's what i get for sprinting across
campus to get here i'm going to define a
number mij
and it's going to be 1 if the substring
s i
oh man 2 j
is in my list of markers p
and 0 otherwise
by the way why is this enough like
notice that i'm not answering which
marker but the problem doesn't really
care right like this problem just checks
if there is a marker and if so then i i
use it yep
so if i have this thing that's going to
somehow make this for loop a heck a lot
easier because now i don't have to do
string matching we'll return to that in
a minute
okay so
my question is how can i compute this
thing and by the way notice that
i know how to compute this when the
difference between i and j is bigger
than
k right because i know that all of my
markers
have length k or less that's gonna be
important because even though m
is doubly indexed uh i don't actually
need to do that in fact i could even
store it uh using less memory than that
if i wanted to by kind of just storing
that that diagonal block
okay uh right
so the other thing which i think we saw
in a previous uh problem session as well
is that when we do a lot of string
matching it often pays
to put our strings into a hash table uh
so that they're easier to look up later
like does this string exist
in this thing or not right rather than
matching every character every single
time
um so maybe we do that just for for for
fun
uh and in general when you see a string
matching problem i might and you have a
list of strings i'd suggest thinking
about hash tables just for
very fun and profit yeah so in step one
here maybe i put
all the strings in p into a hash
okay how much time does that take well i
have to process
every string all right find its code
which is going to take order k time
there's mod p of them so this is k
mod p time notice that that conveniently
agrees with our first term here so we
feel like aha we're in
we're in good shape we're making
progress here um
and now uh maybe i want to fill in this
mij
object here how could i do that well
for one i'm certainly going to have to
iterate over all possible eyes yeah so
let's
uh let's do that so we're going to do
by the way i mean like using ones and
twos and a's and b's and
whatever these are just ways to denote
steps of things
okay so
let's say that i just want to fill in m
um using a brain dead algorithm so i
could go
from one to the size of my strings for i
careful now i can't incur an s squared
but i know that my strings are always at
most length k
so i could do 4 j equals
uh i plus 1
2 i plus k
so this for loop actually incurs k time
not mod s time
and now uh i can do two things right i
can
find the hash
of the string from i to j
right this is going to take order k time
and i can uh search for it
ah
no
[Music]
um to see if it's actually in our
hash table of p and if it is then i set
m equal to 1 otherwise i said m equal to
0.
right and these are our sort of constant
time operations at least at expectation
so how much uh cost to it and so this
you can convince yourself uh fills in
that array m
how much time does it take well i have a
loop to the size of s
i have a loop of size k i have a second
loop of size k here to compute the hash
so this whole thing is going to take
order
k squared mod s time like that
notice conveniently there's chalk on the
floor
and this is uh the second term in our
runtime so this is kosher we can fill in
m and and and and that's a convenient
object to have around
so the only thing that remains is to
revise our r
from above um to make use of the m that
we have uh and that's pretty
straightforward
um
so the trick is to not lean against this
thing and to actually hit the stop
button
i'm learning so now let's suppose we had
t2 for the second t
so for our revised r we should have r
prime
um
what was that that's right the
derivative yeah we could do you know
like christopher symbols like i
j prime semicolon k uh
take six eight three eight if you wanna
learn what christopher symbols are
um right so now
what is my recursive call for x i
well i want to maximize
uh well what can i do i can check every
possible length of a string
that could be in p traffic check if it
is using my ray m
um and and get that amount of profit so
in particular i get
m by the way i keep using the word
profit here i'm essentially
using that to me to increment in every
single one of our problems here i like
to think of our
problems as maximizing profit because
i'm a greedy professor
so this is m i j which would be like 1
if i found a string there and 0 if i'm
not plus
x i plus j to account for the length uh
here where j is in
one two uh well either
the length of the string or i get to the
end of
either the maximum length of a string in
p or i get to the end of my array
like that okay and this is our new
recursive call
the one thing we should double check is
what is the run time for actually
filling in
x now well there's still mod s sub
problems
and now how long does it take well now i
just have one loop
over k things this is mod s times k
it's actually less than any of the terms
that's in our
runtime and so this is fine this
actually
is kind of a funny example where the
dynamic programming part of our
algorithm once we've done all this cute
pre-computation is
actually insignificant um compared to
all the pre-computation that we had to
do uh in our final run time
sneaky all right any questions about uh
protein folding or whatever it is that
we just did
okay so as usual i'm talking too much
yeah which one would you prefer to cut i
have
very few preferences
okay so one of the problems um i would
take a vote but
with our audience there's a high
probability of a split a jury here
um right so there's two remaining
problems in the problem session as usual
uh your instructor
you can leave it there so this is
another problem to learn about um
uh right as usual i've talked too much
and and haven't gotten to the end
i get the impression that in 6006 this
egg drop thing is a bit of a
tradition anyway um so maybe we'll we'll
cover that problem really fast do they
do that in section some variation
not this time even better okay
so yeah so maybe we'll do uh this this
egg drop thing mostly because the other
one i think takes a lot of verbal
setup the other one is is
i would say from a dynamic programming
perspective maybe not super exciting but
from like uh
interesting problem perspective is is
kind of cool
uh to think about um so i'd encourage
you to leave it in there and
you guys can can read it at home um from
a coding perspective it's also kind of
fun
i noticed the solution didn't do what i
would do which would be to use the bits
in the you know like assume that
something wasn't too tall and use the
bits in like an integer to store your
binary variables but that's an old hack
right that's sort of like you know this
this old hack for computing the square
root of a number that's apparently in
the do
the code for the doom video game which
involves like bit shifting and it
happens to agree with square root
for some magic reason that numerical
analysts really hate
um okay so right so uh let's do a lazy
egg drop instead so that's problem four
okay so we're in a building
our building has n floors
um and k eggs
i guess it's debatable whether the
building has eggs or the residents but
in any event i have some set of eggs
and maybe i'm in this data center or
some other weird building so i don't
have
heights of floors that are isotropic
but rather each floor has a different
height which could vary
so it's height of floor
or i really want to write flower um
but i digress uh and we're going to
assume that that our our list is already
sorted
so in other words like the fifth floor
is taller than the fourth floor
and we don't have to like spend analog
and time uh
doing that okay uh right so
apparently in our problem we have an egg
with a mysterious mechanical property
that we are trying to recover
and all eggs as we know are identical so
you know the only difference between
eggs is like chicken versus goose versus
like struggling to think of a third
category of poultry turkey thank you
um right but assuming that i got all of
my eggs at the same stop and shop and
they all come from the same species
then they have roughly the same
mechanical properties actually the
probably the better setup is that floors
are very far apart relative to the size
of an egg
um and if i get high enough
my egg when i drop them on the ground
like that uh breaks didn't break but it
could have broken
and of course if i drop it from an even
higher height
my egg still gets gonna break however
if i have a very low floor apparently a
very low floor maybe this is a house for
mice
um you know when i drop my egg it
actually stays intact
uh and and the question um as all good
scientists want to know is what is the
highest
floor in my building from which i can
drop an egg
and uh have it remain intact
and the question isn't
it's kind of a funny one it's sort of
like this experimental design
in some sense it's it's not asking like
what is the you know like given
this and like a list of experiments you
know try and figure
infer something about the eggs but
rather it's saying
sort of if i carefully design a sequence
of floors
to drop my eggs from from which
upon i dropped my eggs then um
you know in sort of what is the maximum
number of experiments i need to do
to triangulate in on that that floor
that critical floor above which my eggs
break
yep um so what i'm given are the heights
of the floors
and a bunch of eggs in some sense the
budget of eggs
sort of doesn't matter more than just
like putting a cap on the size of
our problem in some sense what really
matters is i'd like to use fewer than k
eggs to determine that because of course
the remaining ones i'm going to use to
make an omelette
but notice that i can be a little sneaky
in my experimental
design that like
what happens if i drop my egg from a
really low floor in my building
well it remains intact so i can
schlep down the stairs i can pick up my
egg and i can use it for my next
experiment
and i have not paid an egg
yeah um so the first question you might
ask
is like well why the heck wouldn't i
just
start on the first floor drop the egg if
it's not broken
you know go on to the next one and then
drop the egg and so on that would be the
most
egg efficient plan and indeed that is
the case
because you'll only break at most one
egg but
you're shopping up and down the stairs a
bunch of times when you solve that right
like every single time you got to go
retrieve
the that unbroken egg you got to run
down the stairs pick the thing up and
then run up to the next floor and maybe
uh in your optimization problem rather
than trying to like minimize the number
of eggs that you break
you're trying to minimize you know the
expense on your
your quads and and and so instead you're
trying you know you you skipped your
leg day or whatever and you're the thing
that you're trying to minimize
is the sum over the heights
of the drops in your experiments right
so you're trying to determine
the um mechanical property of your egg
uh by designing an experiment like like
sort of a procedure
that minimizes the number of times that
you need to to drop
eggs because every time you do you gotta
run all the way back down the stairs and
go look at the pavement and see if the
egg broke or not that's a lot of work
okay uh this is different from the sort
of classic egg drop 6006 problem which i
encourage you guys to go
uh seek out in previous uh iterations of
this course
uh let me see so so right and and so
the the question is what is the minimum
the minimum number
of egg drops you need to do to ascertain
that
for any type of egg yeah so i give you a
mystery back
a basket of eggs and you have to design
an experimental procedure
uh and bound the number of this this
particular value here
given a budget of kx okay
uh and um the amount of time
that we have to do that is order n
cubed k apparently our building
we have lots of eggs and not very many
floors
okay because our setup makes some sense
here
we're just trying to avoid running up
and down the stairs that's the main
takeaway
okay so uh what are we going to do
sort bot because that's all we know how
to do yeah um and
in particular we're going to make one
observation which is kind of handy
if i drop a floor oh if i drop
an egg from a floor
you know in this deterministic universe
where egg
mechanics are very predictable um
there's only one of two things that can
happen either egg broke or didn't
or i run into the board again um so
let's think about our experiment
remember at the end of the day we're
trying to figure out
the tallest floor in my building that i
can safely from which i can
safely drop an egg so if i think about
kind of bracketing that
height of that floor notice that i can
always
for one thing do i ever need a bracket
that's like not a continuous
or like a connected set of numbers the
answer is no right it's never it should
never be the case
that like oh i think that my eggs could
be on floors once you know like only the
prime numbered floors in my building or
something
that really makes no sense right because
if i convince myself my egg breaks at
floor five then obviously floors six
through n
my egg also breaks in so i always can
kind of just keep narrowing down
some interval right uh so
in particular here's kind of a clever s
in my sort bot
which is to say
that i'm going to say that x i j
e is equal to
the minimum by the way this is i'm
writing this as minimum total height
so this is like the minimum total times
i gotta run down the stairs and check my
eggs
um or total height that i run down the
stairs the number of stairs i run down
uh assuming my stairs are one foot tall
um where i have
e eggs left
notice the way that we've written the
problem this time i might as well use
all of my kx like
that doesn't cost me anything what cost
me is running up and down the stairs
um and that i have
floors i through j inclusive
to check so in other words if i'm on a
floor below floor eye i've convinced
myself my egg won't break
that if i'm gonna floor above floor jay
i'm convinced my egg will break
okay so what do i do well remember this
is sort of an experimental design
problem
i can drop my egg from any floor
um f which is
in the range i to
j right and of course there's never a
reason for me to drop an egg
from a floor below i or above j because
we already know what happens in that
case
okay so
what happens uh when we do that well if
i drop it from floor f
i have to pay uh in terms of my cost
function right because i have to pay
the height of f i got to run on the the
stairs
okay um but in exchange for that
i learned a little bit about my egg
problem right i either get an upper or a
lower bound of f depending whether the
egg broke
okay so let's uh let's let's let's let's
formalize that mathematically
so in particular we have x i j
e
well what do i get to control in my life
and what do i have to have to deal with
what i have to deal with is the fact
that i don't know what's going to happen
to the egg it might break it might not
right then the egg might be an
adversarial egg like it wants you to run
up and down the stairs
and i have to account for that but uh i
and the eggs adversary and get to choose
what floor i drop it from
so remember like we saw an example i
forget what from class where there was
sort of a game
right one guy was trying to minimize the
other was trying to maximize
in some sense the egg is trying to
maximize the amount of work you have to
do running up and down the stairs
uh uh to do your experiment a better way
to put it is that we're trying to upper
bound
uh the amount of work in your
experimental procedure
and i'm trying to design a procedure
that minimizes my work right
so let's say that i'm the player so i
want to minimize
um and the decision that i get to make
the control that i have
is what well it's what floor i choose
right so let's say i choose floor f well
i have to go down the stairs so that
takes me hf
i suppose going up the stairs is
probably what incurs the hf and going
down is nothing
um but i digress but now my
i still i'm not done i've narrowed down
into one of two cases right either f
is my new lower bound or my new upper
bound and i have to account for
both of those in my recursion and i have
to take the max of those two
in the sense that i need in every
possible
case that my egg drop experiment narrows
down my floor
uh to to a width of zero
so in particular it's actually a this is
a minimax problem there's a max inside
of them in here
so what's either the egg broke in my
experiment or it didn't
right so if it did broke then
well what happened well let's see here
um
if the egg broke then i got an upper
bound for my floor
so my lower bound remains the same it's
i my upper bound
it's f minus one because it broke on
floor f
well what happens to egg eggs when they
break i can't drop them
from floors again so i lost an egg
okay so this is
my egg
okay or my egg didn't break
so in that case if my egg didn't break
now i have a lower bound
so i'm only unclear about floors f plus
one uh
but the upper bound didn't change is
still j
and how many eggs do i have well my egg
didn't break so i can run down the
stairs which is going to be
tiring right i've accounted for that
here but at least i can reuse my egg so
i didn't lose anything okay
and i get to choose so notice oops
so do you guys see why there's a max
here essentially i have to account for
every possible
scenario when i'm when i'm designing my
experimental procedure
but i get to minimize in the sense that
i can choose what floor at every step
so um right so in particular
uh my f here is in the range
i to j
like that okay and now we have our
recursive formula for our
our egg drop that minimizes total height
um so now
let's uh finish off sort bot in four
minutes it's actually not too hard
so i think we'll actually make it for
once by removing twenty percent of the
problems i'm supposed to cover
right
so first of all what's our topological
order
so
this one seems kind of annoying because
i think usually we think of spending
stuff
in a lot of these uh dynamic programming
problems but do we actually spend an egg
not necessarily right because in this
recursive call
you know the number of eggs i had
remained the same so maybe that's not
actually a great way to
establish a topological order but
instead
what do we know like what is in science
the purpose of an experiment
you know it's to improve our
understanding of the world
in this case our world consists only of
eggs and floors of buildings
um and in particular once i dropped that
egg i learned something about my
building and i
narrowed down the range of floors that
are uncertain for me
so in particular i know that
x i j e
only depends
on x i guess i prime j
prime e prime um
with what well my sub problems i always
have a smaller range of floors than i
did before
so in particular j prime minus
i prime is going to be smaller strictly
than j minus i and that'll give me my
topological order
cool and so that's actually to i think
the sort of annoying part other than
working out this minimax expression here
uh the remaining uh things are not so
hard so
uh what are our base cases well
let's say i have zero eggs left but i
still have a set of
uncertain floors that's bad news
yeah so yeah so that should be
infinity and the reason
um is of course i'm gonna take them in
here
right and so i obviously should never
choose infinity as a min
um so in other words i should never
choose an option for a floor that could
possibly lead me to an
uncertain scenario when i run out of
eggs
yep um in addition to that there's
another base case here
okay so this is like i've got no eggs
left but some floors to check
uh there's a second one
i i minus one
e so in this case i've got e eggs left
and i'm done right
i've narrowed it down to uh uh the the
bounce
incidentally the way i wrote it in terms
of inclusive versus exclusive might be a
little fishy
over here you guys shouldn't be off by
one like your instructor often is
um but in any event you're zero right
there's no more floors left to check
you've narrowed it down to a range of
one again something that i'm out of time
so i'm not going to check carefully is
if my bounds are inclusive should that
be i j minus 1 or i i minus 1 or just i
i but i think you guys are all smart
enough to work that out at home
which would be original case b well now
i have
all the floors to check and all my eggs
in my
metaphorical basket here so i have um
floors one two and here
uh and the problem tells me i have k
eggs when i start
and then finally i need to do my uh
sub problems here
i think you can actually simplify the
argument that's written down a tiny bit
um and just again look at your sub
problems right they're indexed by three
numbers
i'm going to do a really conservative
estimate i think the problem actually
works out a better estimate but then
asymptotically is the same
what's our bound on the first and second
index well they're both
just the index of floors um which which
go between zero and
n yeah obviously you could do better
than that because the lower floor is
always less than the upper floor which
is what the problem accounts for but if
i'm being
lazy then you know well there's
n squared uh sub problems to account for
the two floors
uh and the third index uh is is your
eggs which
you have most kf okay
uh how much work um do we have per
sub problem well uh let's see here
there's a for loop over f f is over
floors
again if i'm going to be really
conservative right well there's at most
uh and uh floors total my building
and so that leads us to a run time of n
cube k which is what we wanted at the
end of the day
okay um
there should be a big o here because i
think technically this is n plus one to
account for floor zero
okay and that uh that solves our egg
drop
uh experiment again i think this is a
nice one and i think in my mind actually
in terms of dynamic programming this is
one of the harder
things to get right which are these sort
of minimax
games you could probably i'd have to
think about it which in my negative two
minutes
i'm not gonna have time to do i think in
in lecture the way that we solve minimax
problem was we separated out the min and
the max and we thought of there being
two
dynamic programming problems that were
sort of interacting with each other you
could
probably write this one in that form as
well i guess just by kind of pulling
this term out
and thinking of it as a different array
um
but this form is perfectly fine too
either one's all right but in my mind
these are sort of the hardest
things to get right in dynamic
programming so i would choose whichever
one
jibes in your brain so uh
in your thing should we choose to leave
it alone there is a fifth problem here
which as usual i haven't managed to get
to
where you're kind of building walls by
placing tiles this is an interesting one
because your runtime is
exponential um but the problem tells you
that that's allowed
but there's like some exponential things
which are okay and some that are not
right like
essentially what you don't want is this
like the product of two giant
exponentials you'd like to just get it
down to one
basically saying it's going to be
polynomial if you have a small height
that's right or it's it's polynomial in
everything except for the things that's
exponential end
and and moreover the things that's
exponential in our are small
and the problem says that so i encourage
you guys to take a look because it
really does take some time to logic
through it but the setup for that
problem is i think longer than
my glacially slow board uh writing can
get handled
um but with that uh we'll call it for
the day
you